dos enemigos históricos unidos por un
factor común Corea del Norte 12 años
después de la última visita de un
premiere japonés a Corea del Sur El
actual jefe de gobierno fumichida fue
recibido en seúl por el presidente
Johnson los dos líderes identificaron al
régimen de Kim jong-un como una amenaza
ambos países están expuestos a las
amenazas nucleares norcoreanas la
cooperación en materia de seguridad es
ahora más importante que nunca en este
sentido subrayaron la alianza con
Estados Unidos como estratégica para
hacer frente a las provocaciones
de acuerdo con la alianza japonesa
Estados Unidos la alianza Corea del Sur
Estados Unidos y la cooperación de
seguridad entre Japón Corea del Sur y
Estados Unidos coincidimos en la
importancia de fortalecer la disuasión y
la capacidad de hacer frente
en medio de la visita se abordaron entre
otros temas el fortalecimiento de la
cooperación en el área de los
semiconductores el vertido regulado de
las aguas residuales de la planta
nuclear de fukushima y la expansión de
las rutas aéreas a nivel prepandémico
Esta visita generó protestas por parte
de los manifestantes quienes exigen
incluir en la agenda de la Cumbre un
tema histórico la ocupación por parte de
Japón de la Península entre 1910 y 1945
Corea del Sur estuvo bajo El dominio
colonial japonés más de 780.000
surcoreanos fueron movilizados para
trabajos forzados o como esclavos
sexuales del ejército en 2015 Japón
presentó una disculpa oficial
comprometiéndose a pagar más de siete
millones de dólares a un fondo de ayuda
a las víctimas de la guerra pero el
acuerdo Fue cancelado más tarde por
Corea del Sur con este encuentro
siguen dispuestos a enterrar el hacha de
guerra entre sus naciones